hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and on this week's winners on a
wednesday i want to introduce you to a
guy called pete
pete's got a little portfolio up north
that he's built up over the years
he's very successful in property and
he's going to share with you the golden
nuggets the tricks and tips
how he's become financially free through
investing in property so pete thanks so
much for coming on the show
appreciate you mates fantastic to be
with you man well it's really good to
meet you i think this is the first time
i've ever met in person yeah
absolutely because you've been doing all
the online training oh it's just been
brilliant it's been a game changer for
me
i'm really really pleased to hear it so
you've been investing in property for
ages
yeah but only about a year ago you just
changed it all up since doing the
training
absolutely tell me your background how
did you get started in property in 2008
um what were you doing at the time for a
job yeah how did this all start
yeah so um 2008 i've always been a
career man
in it and in construction um so 2008 we
ran some training courses
with the church on entrepreneurial ship
and off the back of that i bought two
properties for
for five grand each off plan and then
the builder put ten percent in so we
could just do it with the deposits
and then we had a mortgage and for the
you know for the past
years i've just been getting about 300
quid for both flats a month cash flow on
them okay so you know they've been
better than in the bank to be honest
so you just bought a couple of
properties a couple little apartments
yeah sat on them rented them out and
that and that's that
yeah right very little money down it was
it was 10 grand in
and 300 pounds forever yeah since i've
had them so it's been good you know
they've been good little investment
yeah so and then 2019
i was really fed up i wasn't enjoying
the job at the time
and i just wanted to get full-time in
property yeah
so i decided new year's resolution
january the 1st i'm gonna get
buy a house how am i gonna do it i
borrowed 50 grand off tesco and
sainsbury's oh it's personal
yeah oh wow okay three percent so i
think over the
the whole of the term of the loan i was
paying two grand each or something on
them
yeah for the interest so it's nothing
it's crazy it is
uh credit score was great which enabled
me to do it
and then i bought a three-bedroom
semi-detached house in sheffield
it was a deceased estate i bought 140
000
knew nothing about refurbs knew nothing
about anything
didn't know about finance got ripped off
on fees
all of that and spent 25 grand on
doing it up and the finances and
everything so it was 165 in
yeah and then in january 2020
after i tried to sell it and was
unsuccessful because of brexit
no one wanted to buy a house because
they were waiting for brexit at that
time
so i revalued it and pulled and for 195.
okay so you made 30 grand 65 to one
night if i was well chuffed with it yeah
okay so you went from a couple flats in
2008 yeah got
got the taste for property yeah 2019 you
were like man
i'm tired of not having property i got
it borrowed money from the bank
yeah which is smart yeah and and paid
three percent interest and bought a
property
yeah push the value up a little bit yeah
and then what happened
so got the money out from that one
rented that one out so it's proper brr
uh 750 a month on that one yeah cash
flows 350
a month so that's great so that one's
just you know earning me income so i've
got a 300
350 so 650 cash flow at this point
and then i found your channel on your
job
yeah yeah so march 20 i found samuel
lee's channel
and it was just a complete game change
of like my right
it was as if like blinds had come off my
eyes
yeah i've been doing things
enthusiastically
but didn't have a clue how to do it so
yeah in june of 2020 i put an offer in
on this house
of 66 000 and that
offer got accepted this is the house
that we're sitting in right now yeah
yeah so the reason i bought this one was
i was going for the
buy low rent high strategy that i found
in your book
yeah so i had the book read the book and
i might
it was just like so if i just wish that
i'd
bought two houses at 66
instead of one at 140. crazy they've
been able to make the same profit on
this one
yeah or even more profit on this one
than i did on the one that i
bought for 140. and again like with
property you did property previously
with no training
you just you know you used your common
sense and you got a little bit of a
background in construction
yeah um so you thought i'm going to use
my comments i'm going to go for it and
don't go wrong you did well
yeah properties you did all right but
then when you started watching the
youtube videos reading the books you
thought actually
i could do this more sophisticated yeah
right i could really i could really ramp
this up
um and you you learned the actual
formulas of the bio refurbishing finance
strategy
yeah so you bought this house that we're
in right now paid 66 grand for it yeah
which is half the price that you
previously paid for the price which you
thought was a good deal it was
um and then how much did you spend on
this house uh so the refurb
for the roofing and and the building
work and the plastering and everything
kit new kitchen
new bathroom decoration everything doing
to it yeah and i've converted this to
hmo so
new fire doors new fire eggs new wall
at the front there to to make another
bedroom so it's four bed
so that cost me 12 grand for all of that
not bad
and then the furniture washers fridge
freezers all of that type of stuff
three run for that so 15 total taking me
up to 81
yeah football in and then
everything and then the new value now
yeah so it was
it was revalued by three estate agents
one was 110
and two were 120. i think probably
somewhere in the middle of them too
maybe so you've pushed the value up
like crazy yeah it's been insane and i
think barnes has gone up
during the crisis anyway because people
are buying so many houses so
it's gone up from eight from 81 in to
about 115
so i think the profit's about 30 grand
so let me ask you a question any idiot
can buy a house and make money yeah
because properties tend to go up over
time
yeah everyone needs to rent a house so
anyone can just buy a house and make
money
what did you do differently since going
on the training
joining samuel 365 reading the books
what did you do differently what were
some of the clever things that you did
in your investment strategies that you
didn't do previously
yeah so i think for me
after i'd read the books and watch the
youtubes i was looking for an
area then i'm looking for somewhere
where i could buy
cheap houses good value houses that are
near the center that will rent out for
good money and can make into an
hmo or a really good cash flow in buy to
lay
yeah so in sheffield at the moment we've
seen a massive increase in houses you
can't buy a terry styles less than 100
grand in sheffield now really
so i had to find somewhere else yeah the
fine with the money and because i'd read
the books and watch the youtubes
i was more clever about what i was
looking for so i'm looking for something
with big
bedrooms yeah i can let i'm looking for
somewhere that's near the town
yeah i'm looking for a place that will
rent easily and i'm looking for
something that i've got
absolutely you know stuff that's
terrible that i can't deal with so
yeah this house came up on the market
it's got three big size bedrooms
it's 250 yards from the town and
barnsley's moving to article four in may
25
which is huge yeah because sheffield's
already article four yeah
so sheffield you've missed the boat so
you found an area that was buy low rent
high
cheap yeah you bought it for 66 grand
you've pushed the value up to 120.
you've almost doubled the value with a
12 grand refurb
and you're renting this out now what
you've got tenants obviously
just finished the refurb yeah what's the
um kind of rent on this now
so there's a building company coming
around on saturday to confirm
the rental of the whole house and the
rent's
1500 pound gross a month right which is
incredible
yes and that's just to a building
company that's like a corporate let
yeah so all you'll have to pay is bills
council tax
wi-fi and stuff like that yeah your
mortgage payments what profit you're
going to be left with
so i think it's going to cash flow 800
pound a month
incredible after everything so 1500
gross rent
and then 800 cash flow yeah including 10
management fees yeah and you're going to
refinance it
yeah it's with steve at the moment
refinance steve bench
yeah great so he's thinking that we'll
probably get at least 110 on the reval
and that'll mean i can pull out 40 grand
well you'll pull out all the money you
put in right yeah
plus some extra so you're getting paid
to have a house
yeah that is something else i mean if it
varies at 110 yeah
you'll pull out all your money yeah be
able to reinvest it into something else
um so so i guess the key the key things
are number one is area
yeah you found a good area number two is
um article four yeah about the rules
yeah see this this house that we're in
you don't need a license no we're going
to be planning
but you will when's this going to come
article 4. so may the 25th is the
deadline
right so you got to get tenants in by
then yeah and then you have grandfather
rights
yeah so it's one of the key selling
points of it really when i was looking
around
so you've done a brr hmo combined
bringing in 800 pound a month you've
also got a rent to rent
yeah where's that tell me about that
yeah so november 20 i
i got a there was a facebook post for a
managing agent in nottingham
yeah so they do the sa management it's
15
and this they got some two-bedroom
beautiful two-bedroom apartments 50
yards from the castle in nottingham
so like right in the town centre um on
hounds gate so they
they're a thousand pound rent to the
landlord
and the cash flow between 500 and a
thousand
a month so 500 not in the summer months
about a thousand quid in the in the
summer right
um so and i didn't know about our
entrance before i found your channel
yeah so i won't have even had a sniff of
that if i um
found you so you've like doubled your
cash flow now or more
yeah so i was on 650 cash flow before
samuel 365 and i've pulled in 1300 extra
passive income since i joined
oh so you've like tripled yeah that's
really impressive yeah it's insane
so it's completely changed my life
so you know before i mean i do really
enjoy
my job still which is why i probably
haven't quit yet
um but i could see myself once i've paid
the debt off that i took out
in 19 which is like next year or
something so you were getting 650 a
month in rent
but that took you like 10 years yeah so
it took you 10 years
of graft to get 650 a month and then
suddenly in the space of
12 months you've got two grand a month
it's just been insane
and i've got i've just accepted an offer
on
another house exactly the same as this
one yeah two streets over
so tell me about that one so yeah
commercial street it's a three-bedroom
terrace
it's got a two story extension on the
back this one's one story
um so that one yeah i didn't even think
i was going to be able to buy it
because i didn't have the money so i'm
waiting for the refinance from steve
me and the mrs have probably got about
15 grand but we need 23 to complete
including stamp duty on commercial
street
right so we've kind of given up on it as
an idea to be honest but
whenever i was looking at them right
move for any other deals
i'd keep coming back to that one it was
the best deal yeah so
so in essence i put a forum post on
the s365 forum looking for a jb
partner for 10 grand and within the
space of half an hour i have three
people who offered me the money oh wow
so you've got the money now i've got the
money
yeah they're going to give me the money
on completion great and then for six
months until we've
refinanced absolutely fabulous yeah so
that that's just
i wouldn't have been able to afford to
go again
until another eight weeks until my all
the money
came in yeah raising finance that's the
power yeah
so i just never thought it would ever
happen yeah but it
you know it ended up being within half
an hour
and three offers so it's just unreal
what
what what is for anyone that's wondering
what is s365 like what what is that
so yeah s365 samuel 365 is a monthly
program
where you get access to samuel's mentors
and and samuel obviously
and if you've got any problems that
you're facing in your journey
through property you can speak to a
mentor about that
we also have these 365 mastermind calls
on a wednesday where we all get together
celebrate successes and help people out
with the struggles
and the other thing i find really
helpful is to be able to just chat to
people
in the network about deals that we found
and
things that we're looking at and whether
they really are a goal we just need
people to bounce off sometimes to yeah
to work out whether it's got legs or
anything so
yeah i hope that's explained yeah no it
has really well
and there is an investment involved you
invest in yourself i always say
invest in yourself before you invest in
property yeah because
you can make money in property but it
might be slow and hard and problems
whereas if you know what you're doing
and you've got support and mentors
you're going to get them a lot faster a
lot quicker
there's an investment but it's not
expensive in my opinion i agree
i mean before to well just after 2019
when i did my first one
if i'd have had the network and the
knowledge prior to that
i'd i've doubled the amount of
properties by now i think yeah
that's brilliant and you've also um
through samuel 35 you
co-sourced a deal yeah i mean that paid
for your membership for about six months
yeah it did yeah so that was i've become
compliant
um just after i started s365
so i thought well i don't have to do one
deal in order to pay for the
for the um the compliance that i did
yeah
and then yeah this one kind of paid for
the
the training and yeah it was just
somebody who got a deal
and got an investor yeah and wanted to
co-source it with me because i'm
compliant so
so that was really great so what was
some of the um
because you don't love packaging and
selling deals no you
you don't like to find investors you're
not finding the deals
what what is it that you look for in a
deal
what what give me the tricks and tips
yeah so
for me personally uh i'm looking for
something that i can add
value enough so that i can pull all my
money back out of it
yeah and not spend a lot of money right
so
so for me i'm looking for areas like
rotherham
barnsley burnley places that are
low in price on property yeah but
there's really great demand for renting
houses out which is like most of the
north at the moment yeah
so i think in some ways the northeast
and this sort of
yorkshire area is missed a lot of people
like liverpool
yeah but this area is there's a lot of
investment and a lot of property here
that you can
go in add value to it and then refinance
it and pull your money
out yeah but you only need 20 grand to
do it
whereas if you were in exeter or
somewhere like that you're gonna need 50
grand to do it or more
yeah so he's just being able to leverage
that money what would you say to
somebody though that said but aren't
the those cheap areas don't they have
like bad tenants everywhere and
housing benefits at streets and it could
be a bit of a rough area so they want to
invest in places like exeter
because they think that the tenants are
going to be a better quality
what would you say to that i'd say that
every city area is like monopoly
you've got bad areas and good areas so
you've got the old camp roads
and you've got the mayfairs in barnsley
in sheffield
yeah and all over the cities that you
have so they'll always they'll all have
good areas and bad areas
like this particular area is a main
artery out of the city so it's well
looked after the council care for it
well
and the tenants care for it well yeah
whereas probably two or three streets
over you might have somewhere where you
could drop litter and nobody'd be
bothered about
right so you've got to make sure that
you know the area before you buy that
you can't just say
oh barnsley's good and by blind you have
to
do your due diligence to check what this
what the good and the bad areas are
yeah and these state agents are helpful
for that you know yeah i'll say
you know what will this revalue for well
it's on at 60 it'll revalue at 70 after
refurb
so i'm like well i'm not touching that
it's going to take me 10 runs to refurb
it anyway yeah
so i tend to just speak to the agents
who've got the knowledge
and also i talk to the the person who's
showing me around if they're
the owner or tenant they'll tell me yeah
whether the
it's gone down here or pill or it's
better or i think asking questions and
listening
is really important to agents to sellers
and you can't take everybody's word for
it yeah that's why you have to ask
multiple people
and you have to know what you're doing
but i guess to say
oh up the north the tenants will be bad
because it's cheap it's quite an
arrogant thing to say really isn't it
i mean you're you're from sheffield
yourself so to say
to say oh because it's a cheap area the
people are bums it's like no it's just a
cheap area
well there are some streets in sheffield
where the houses are two million pound a
piece
right and there's parts and there's
parts of london which are really rough
yeah and as you said there's good and
there's bad yeah but it's about finding
an area where you got
and i actually think i don't know what
you found but i don't want to buy in
the the really well sought after areas
i don't want to buy in the really rough
areas yeah i kind of want to get like
middle of the road yeah i'd probably say
if one
was horrible and 10 was mayfair
i'd want to be looking for like three
and a half maybe four
yeah sort of that type of area and that
way there's room for growth
i want to buy the worst house on the
best street
absolutely i'm wanting to buy in an area
where i've got good management companies
in place
where ultimately i'm going to get a good
yield i'm going to get a good return on
investment cash on cash
yeah i find exactly the same and i think
and i think in some ways
you know in the brr strategy i just
think if i can make the same profit
for a house that i bought at 66 000 then
i did one at 140
yeah then i can do two or three of them
yeah you know so
yeah so that is leveraging your finances
better than anything and i love the fact
that you're renting it to a company
yeah because then there's no hassle yeah
it's all one company and the builders so
something goes wrong with the building
they can just fix it themselves
absolutely yeah if it's a building
company
so true so let me ask you a question
pete what what's your strongest reason
for doing this
okay so this kind of goes back to
to again my faith so so similar to you i
want to be able to resource
people that are suffering and struggling
yeah so
my wife she's from the philippines and
there's a lot of need in the philippines
over there especially at the moment with
the weather and everything that they're
having
where we just want to bless people yeah
you know we want to give to people
we want to help people and obviously for
ourselves we want to
work less hard for ourselves as well you
know we want to enjoy our life and
and you know be abroad and on holiday
and and those sort of things as well so
it's about the standard of our life
yeah but then also about blessing other
people is really where we're at
that's great and you can't i guess you
can't help the poor by being poor
yourself
yeah so i mean and you know you know my
story and
i had a real as a christian i had a real
grapple with this this idea of being a
wealthy businessman but also being a
christian
and i realized that actually money
doesn't doesn't make you a good person
or a bad person it just
helps you become more of what you
already are what you want to become yeah
and it brings choices if you're a jerk
and you have a lot of money
you'll be a bigger jerk but if you want
to help people
and you have money it's going to enable
you to do that more so that's why i love
helping people like you
because you're the same elk yeah you
want to help people so helping you make
money
and your family is just a really really
good thing yeah it's one of the things i
really love about the network as well
because i feel like because i've done a
few now
i've got something to give to the others
that are in their 365 as well you know
i'm going to help them along and
and point them to the mentors and point
them to some of the brr stuff
we've done and really help people who
want to welcome themselves really as
well
it's so funny because it's far there's
such great people on that but it's just
there's such a diverse mix there's some
people that are millionaires
yeah you know we have people like mark
parham yeah he's making millions
and he's on every week yeah this i did i
made this many millions this week you
know it's just crazy but then you've
also got people that are like teenagers
yeah doing rent to rent and just
starting out and then exciting to watch
these youngsters
you know do well and and get out of the
rat race and and yeah really invest in
well some of them will never have to
have a job
yeah some of them and it's crazy it is
crazy
and you see it for every week on the on
the mastermind calls you see it
firsthand you see these
19 20 year olds are like are making the
grand a month for making three grand
with their renter rents um and and their
deal packaging
yeah and it's absolutely incredible and
then like you you've
your mortgage broker your code sources
all these people
this this power team it's just so
valuable it is it is valuable so what's
next thing for you what can we expect to
see over the next 12 months
okay so done the business plan which is
that i want to do four
brrs a year yeah to start with um so
i've managed to get my pension into my
what's called a sas now
so that allows me to invest in in houses
in my pension
right so i'm doing that and then i'm
going to jv
with more people from s365 so i can do
deals that i wouldn't have been able to
do before yeah we're hoping to do four
brrs a year and
six deal source co-source deals with the
likes of graziella and gemma and people
on the network i don't like selling
deals but i love finding them
yeah i'm looking around houses all the
time for myself to to
build stuff and renovate and the ones
that i can't buy
why let them go i might as well make
1500 quid a piece out of them as well
absolutely it's just the power of the
network and it's like if you like
finding deals
but you know selling them yeah there's
other people that like selling them
without finding them yeah so you can
just joint venture and that's the power
of mastermind
what would you say to somebody that was
thinking of joining samuel 365.
i'd say just get straight on it it's
just been revolutionary for me
you know it's changed my life up within
the next couple of years i'll i'll be
full-time in property
and moving towards 20 houses in the
portfolio
incredible that you know it's just
insane the way things have accelerated
because of the program
well dude honestly massive respect
congrats thanks for having me around
your house
you know thanks for everything you're
doing for me you're very welcome it's a
pleasure
great job if you found that useful
please do me
and pete a massive favor smash the like
button also drop a comment below for
peace
if you would like to try out samuel 365
if you'd like to become a member
check it out see what it's all about you
can do that for
one pound seven day trial for one pound
and thereafter it's 95 pounds a month
there's no cancellation charges or
anything like there's no contracts
try it out would you agree pete
i'll leave a link in the description
below where you can try out samuel 365.
also join me at the property investors
crash course it's 12 days
where i've condensed everything i know
about property into a 12-hour training
program
called the property investors crash
course again it's one
pound you can do it virtually from home
there really is no excuses
get booked on i'll leave a link in the
description and i look forward to seeing
you
real soon thanks for watching god bless
you